good afternoon and welcome today we
begin what intentionally will be a
continuing conversation about the global
implications of nuclear testing this
event was initiated by the mission of
the Republic of Kazakhstan to the United
Nations in New York as a school we are
committed to social justice in assuring
the health and quality of life of all
members of the human race thus we join
with the Republic of Kazakhstan without
any hesitation whatsoever in recognizing
the first international day against
nuclear tests that was observed this
past August twenty-ninth indeed we
acknowledge Kazakhstan for its
introduction of resolutions 6435 which
established the International Day the
school is particularly pleased as we
have been working with an in Kazakhstan
for nearly a decade as through our
nearly 40 staff members who are
associated with our Global Health
Research Center in Almaty special thanks
to the office of President Lee Bollinger
of Columbia University for its very
significant support of this event many
of us regard with horror the unspeakable
tragedy and devastation wrought in
Hiroshima and Nagasaki Japan in 1945 but
nuclear tests are not a thing of the
past semi politan sque in Kazakhstan the
Pacific Ocean near Hawaii and sites in
New Mexico and Nevada have been among
the many locations used for more than
2,000 nuclear tests conducted worldwide
between 1945 and 2008 thus we are a
species threatened by extinction by our
own hand however UN Secretary Ban
ki-moon has observed that and I called a
world free of nuclear weapons would be a
global public good of the highest order
we are honored this afternoon to have a
panel of Luminara
is to offer their expert perspectives on
issues related to nuclear testing the
possibility of a comprehensive
nuclear-test-ban treaty disarmament and
our roles and responsibilities related
to securing the future of humankind each
panelist deserves a much longer
introduction than I will provide but I
am under very strict orders to be
concise ambassador tobor tov tov is the
executive secretary of the preparatory
commission for the comprehensive
nuclear-test-ban treaty organization a
hungarian career diplomat with
experience measured in decades he was
permanent representative from Hungary to
the United Nations and other
international organizations into the
conference on Disarmament ambassador
Toth was ambassador-at-large for
nonproliferation and critical
technologies he has served as an garion
deputy State Secretary of Defense and is
permanent representative to the
preparatory Commission of the
organization for the prohibition of
chemical weapons in The Hague ambassador
Toth is on the board of governors of the
International Atomic Energy Agency he
participated in the negotiations of the
Chemical Weapons Convention and has
played a critical role in the
preparatory commission for the
organization for the prohibition of
chemical weapons dr. Randy Riedel a
senior political affairs officer with
united nations office for disarmament
affairs he has served as advisor to
Under Secretary General's of the United
Nations and in senior leadership
positions for commissions advisory
boards and associations focused on
disarmament arms control and weapons of
mass destruction dr. Rydell has been a
visiting lecturer at Princeton's Woodrow
Wilson School he is an international
political analyst studying the political
spread of excuse me the global spread of
nuclear weapons it was on the staff of
former US Senator John Glenn an author
attorney and international advocate
sir jonathan groff is president of the
global security institute as well as
senior advisor to the American Bar
Association's Committee on arms control
and national security his culture of the
ABA Blue Ribbon task force a nuclear
non-proliferation and serves on the
fortune forum the Jane Goodall Institute
and the NGO Committee on disarmament
peace and security and middle powers
initiative mr. granoff is also the
award-winning screenwriter of the
Constitution the document that created a
nation and as articles in more than 50
publications and books I think you've
probably seen him as a guest on a number
of television shows he is a senior
advisor to the Nobel Peace Laureate
summit and since 2003 has addressed the
annual Nobel Peace Laureate summit in
Paris and Rome before hearing from our
panelists I am most pleased to introduce
her excellency Madame burningham al Tim
ova the permanent representative for the
mission of the Republic of Kazakhstan to
the United Nations ms Alton mova has
held various positions in the Kazakhstan
government from 2004 until her current
appointment she was in bath scuze me
Minister of Education and science
previously the Ambassador served as
deputy prime minister as an ambassador
to Italy and earlier and ambassador to
Israel ambassador Ultima VII was a
senator and a member of parliament she
was a minister of youth affairs tourism
and sport and deputy chairman of the
Soviet Children's Fund section she is a
remarkable leader an inspiring
individual and she understands the
importance of engaging our young people
as her now international career
trajectory was actually rooted in her
initial work as a public school teacher
please join me in welcoming her
excellency ambassador eltham ova
thank you very much for your actually
having one or two hours around 12 time
to hear what is the amazing and
knowledgeable and very famous on the
whole planet experts are going to share
some kind of use about future of our
planet let's embrace together the future
without nuclear weapons this is the main
idea why we actually asked very very
highly requested Columbia University and
especially the social school faculty it
is probably unusual to have such kind of
events such kind of meetings discussions
in this school not like in international
relations school ends also and I would
like from the bottom of my heart express
appreciation to everybody who is today
especially on the podium and extremely
important for us for all of us having
you today in the hole hole dear dr.
Janet Nakamura mr. Tibor taught our two
great speakers Randy Riedel and Jonathan
Granof dear faculty and students of
Columbia University it gives me great
pleasure to organize this event with the
Columbia School of Social Work our joint
collaboration is meant to propel the
dynamism of youth as the next generation
leaders for their our best resource for
the future the 29 of August will mark
the first observance of the
International Day
against nuclear tests actually from the
beginning we wanted to have
international day against nuclear
weapons but you can imagine some
countries still not ready yet to support
such kind of idea then after many many
discussions we had and we got some
compromise and we said that they at
least for educational purpose for day
with fresh breath with the meaning of
huge without nuclear tests it's almost
one step to taught our global without
nuclear weapons the International Day
was established at the initiative of the
government of Kazakhstan through a
resolution of the General Assembly which
was adopted unanimously on the second
December last year this is the day when
President my president northolt another
buyer Union laterally with the
Presidential Decree closed down 29 19
years ago then you clear test site in
Sinop Alliance the second largest test
site in the world and we are going to
shows a short film not so short but 21
20 minutes but we promise you that you
have to trust me that we were requested
by some countries to keep this nuclear
test site and to keep number 4 ledges
nuclear arsenal which was we kept in our
hands add after the collapse of Soviet
Union in our hands in Kazakhstan and we
were promised to finance all nuclear
arsenal in Kazakhstan but we didn't do
it and we see your witness that we shut
down without any kind of request of
international community by the way the
day is
meant to fuel the action of the United
Nations member states inter government
and non-governmental organizations
academic institutions youth networks and
the media towards nuclear disarmament
and non-proliferation it is meetings
like this that generate advocacy to put
pressure on governments to bring the
early entry into force of the
comprehensive nuclear-test-ban treaty
which mr. taught it will speak about our
vision is also to carry fold the
recommendations of the 2010 may nuclear
non-proliferation treaty review
conference so that we can aim for a safe
and more secure well today this will be
highlighted by our second speaker mr.
Randy Riedel we want all segments of
society especially the youth to be
engaged in action and advocacy to
abolish nuclear weapons once and for all
it is said that a picture says a
thousand words but so to set the tone of
our discussions we have especially made
a film for you to review it is called
embrace and what we do embrace a world
free of nuclear weapons of course it
shows the history and horrors of nuclear
testing as well as the hope of humankind
to have a safe and better world of
course I would I want actually even now
to share a lot of knowledge a lot of
information with you about the reason
why we did it about the suffer what we
had it and still have it and but we
prepared and you will see through the
whole film today this is still not about
Kazakhstan this is it will be a very
small part of Kazakhstan's situation
with a nuclear test site by the name of
Semipalatinsk but this is the field of
the actual film of the history of
nuclear weapons and what we had in
history what we have and in order not to
have it we have two to be together and
to understand what does it mean well
with nuclear weapon or world without
nuclear weapon only one thing I would
like to add still today in Semipalatinsk
region this is one and half million
population the territory as today's
modern German s territory that is was
influenced by almost 500 nuclear tests
during 40 years at Semipalatinsk nuclear
test site and still have we the pictures
you'll see some pictures but I am
witness I visited that places and
special hospitals and you I saw there 12
years old child like this one without
legs and without arms and I saw the
picture of two heads child which were
born late after in this territory nobody
knows but one thing scientists confirm
that some sports of nuclear weapon tests
I'd never might be recovered and you can
come to my country or to Japan auto in
other places in the world and you will
feel yourself and Yossi but before I
conclude I would like to offer my most
heartful thanks to gene J dr. Jeanette
camera on rubber ouble Stacey cos and
Francesca bertolini due to whom today's
meeting happened the audience of the
president of Columbia University for its
support for this meeting the united
nations office for disarmament affairs
represented here by Randy Riedel and
John eNOS
the Department of Public Information the
civil society represented by Jonathan
grin off of course our leading leading
organization I want to have to say like
this and to have it ctbto chichi bar
thought and our dearest Anika they end
of course you all students young
generation for your invaluable support
to us in our outreach effort thank you
very much actually I'm not going to
speak very much about substantive issue
of that my president was really became
initiated initially initiator of
international day without nuclear tests
why because next year we are going to
celebrate really celebrate 20 years
after closing number two in the world
the largest nuclear weapon tests side
thank you for your attention
after decades of living with the threat
of nuclear war and total annihilation a
popular movement to abolish nuclear
weapons once and for all is exploding
around the world this idea begins the
final chapter in a story of struggle
between two competing views one that
held nuclear weapons are a fact of
modern life and those who say they are
morally wrong and should be abolished
that story begins in Japan at the close
of World War two on August six nineteen
forty-five the Atomic Age begins with
the bombing of Hiroshima the blast from
a bomb named little boy destroys most of
the city 140,000 people are killed
Nagasaki Japan is destroyed by a second
atomic bomb on the 9th of August 80,000
people are killed World War 2 is over
but the misery from burns and radiation
poisoning continues the destructive
power of nuclear weapons is witnessed
with horror by the world the world had
already responded to the horrors of
World War 2 by establishing the United
Nations in 1945 to maintain
international peace and security in 1946
reflecting the hopes of people
everywhere the first meeting of the
United Nations General Assembly commits
itself to work for the elimination from
national armaments of atomic weapons and
of all other major weapons adaptable to
mass destruction the United States
learns that its monopoly on the atomic
bomb is over on August twenty-ninth 1949
when the Soviet Union demonstrates its
atomic bomb on the steppes of Kazakhstan
and with that blast an uneasy balance of
nuclear terror is struck between the two
emerging superpowers
with their opposing political ideologies
the nuclear arms race begins Great
Britain joins the nuclear Club in 1952
as the possibility of annihilation by
nuclear war becomes an emerging reality
people around the world begin to speak
out
despite the growing opposition by
religious leaders governments and
citizens groups the nuclear arms race
continues Albert Einstein and the
well-known philosopher Bertrand Russell
release a manifesto declaring that
hydrogen and atomic weapons have become
so dangerous that war must be banned
writing that they fear if many bombs are
used there will be universal death
sudden only for a minority but for the
majority a slow torture of disease and
disintegration at the United Nations the
Soviet Union proposes the creation of
nuclear weapons free zones yet the arms
raised driven by nuclear testing goes on
tests on both sides continue under water
underground and in the air atmospheric
tests create radioactive fallout
breathed in it triggers cancer and other
illnesses on the ground fallout poisons
the food chain the environmental effects
of nuclear testing spur public outrage
worldwide the campaign for nuclear
disarmament in the United Kingdom
demands that Great Britain give up its
nuclear arsenal and asked the United
States and the Soviet Union to do the
same in America streets women lead
protests over the discovery of
radioactive fallout in milk
still the nuclear Club adds to its
membership France conducts its first
nuclear test
growing concern among people and
governments leads to a major diplomatic
step away from nuclear war the signing
in 1963 of the partial test-ban treaty
by the United States the Soviet Union
and Great Britain
the treaty limits the effects of nuclear
testing on humans animals and the
environment but has no impact on the
nuclear arms race between east and west
nuclear testing moves underground and
the number of tests increase greatly in
1964 China conducts its first nuclear
test
throughout the decade nuclear stockpiles
grow in size and sophistication driven
by the doctrine of mutual assured
destruction nuclear conflict is to be
avoided or deterred by the threat of a
massive retaliation with nuclear weapons
against the side that uses them first
deterrence strategy requires that
hundreds of millions die and that the
world itself be destroyed by radioactive
fallout war is no longer about defeating
enemies in battle but the destruction of
humanity people around the world respond
to the doctrine of mutual assured
destruction without rage most nations
especially those that are not aligned
with the United States or the Soviet
Union believe that their safety lies in
ending the arms race and abolishing
nuclear weapons by 1968 the United
Nations General Assembly approves the
text of the treaty on the
non-proliferation of nuclear weapons for
NPT to prevent the spread of nuclear
weapons and weapons technology to
advance nuclear disarmament and to
promote cooperation in the peaceful uses
of nuclear energy yet ten years after
the adoption of the nuclear
non-proliferation treaty the United
States still has more than 24,000
nuclear weapons the Soviet Union 25,000
and together Great Britain France and
China have hundreds more a single
nuclear bomb in use by the united states
air force in 1978 was nearly 500 times
as powerful as little boy the bomb that
destroyed hiroshima together the nuclear
arsenals of the United States and Soviet
Union combined contained the explosive
power of 1.5 million little
deaths from a full-scale nuclear
exchange are estimated in the billions
the aftermath is described as a nuclear
winter where radioactive dust and debris
block the Sun destroying the earth's
ecosystem and starving additional
billions of people alarmed by the
accelerating arms race the United
Nations General Assembly convenes for
its first special session on disarmament
the goal is to work toward a global
strategy to end the nuclear arms race
the General Assembly declares mankind is
confronted with a choice we must halt
the arms race and proceed to disarmament
or face annihilation the confrontation
between east and west has many fearing
that the specter of a nuclear war is
becoming a permanent fixture in the
lives of all the world's citizens across
the globe civil society groups embarked
on a different confrontation in the
united kingdom as many as 70,000
individuals protest at the Greenham
common airbase where US weapons are
deployed in the united states a rally
against nuclear weapons in New York's
Central Park draws nearly a million
people
whether it was for strategic military
reasons effective diplomacy or in
response to the growing chorus against
nuclear weapons President Reagan of the
United States and general secretary
Mikhail Gorbachev of the Soviet Union
order their mid-range missiles removed
from Europe and destroyed it is the
first time nuclear-armed states have
agreed to eliminate an entire class of
weapons the removal of intermediate
range missiles from Europe adds energy
to the growing civil society movement to
abolish all nuclear weapons in
Kazakhstan decades of testing at semi
polyp tents has sickened thousands and
caused terrible environmental damage a
movement to eliminate nuclear testing
springs up a sister organization in
Nevada home of the u.s. test site joins
the Cossacks to underscore the
importance of a global nuclear test ban
the development of nuclear weapons is
driven by nuclear testing tests have
occurred all over the world the united
states and the soviet union between them
conducted nearly 2,000 tests the united
states conducted a total of 1032 tests
in the pacific and at its test sites in
and around nevada the soviet union
conducted 715 nuclear explosions at semi
Paula tents in the Arctic and elsewhere
around the Soviet Union hundreds more
have been conducted by China France and
the United Kingdom
the semi pallet tent site is an
environmental disaster for over 15
million causes the soil and groundwater
have been contaminated by radiation from
some 468 nuclear tests in the same year
that the berlin wall comes down
symbolically ending the Cold War the
Soviet Union conducts its last nuclear
weapons test at semi Paula tens
the United Kingdom conducts its last
test in 1991 and testing in Nevada stops
in 1992 by this time nuclear testing has
led to approximately 60,000 nuclear
weapons other parts of the world choose
to become nuclear weapons free zones
Latin America and the Caribbean Africa
Central and Southeast Asia the South
Pacific and Mongolia with the breakup of
the Soviet Union the United States and
the new Russian Federation agreed to
make major reductions in their nuclear
arsenals a number of nuclear-capable
states that may have been envisioning a
nuclear weapons program have abandoned
them South Africa developed nuclear
weapons then destroyed its capability
prior to joining the non-proliferation
treaty in 1999 Kazakhstan Ukraine and
Belarus gave up nuclear weapons after
the breakup of the Soviet Union momentum
for a global ban on nuclear testing
builds in 1994 the united nations
conference on Disarmament in Geneva
Switzerland begins negotiations on a
comprehensive nuclear-test-ban treaty
the CTBT a treaty that will ban all
nuclear explosions the United States
continues its moratorium on testing
other members of the nuclear Club feel
the pressure from civil society to
comply France closes its test site in
the South Pacific with the CTBT months
away from a vote in the United Nations
China stages a final weapons test then
declares its own moratorium the text of
the comprehensive nuclear-test-ban
treaty is approved in the United Nations
General Assembly by a vote of 158 in
favor
an end to nuclear explosions seems
inevitable India which conducted a
single test in 1974 tests again in 1998
Pakistan responds with an underground
testing program of its own
people's concerns echo the findings of
the independent Canberra Commission set
up by Australia in 1995 so long as any
state has nuclear weapons others will
want them so long as any such weapons
remain it defies credibility that they
will not one day be used by accident
miscalculation or design the fear also
exists that a small group could steal or
buy nuclear materials to make a bomb
easily smuggled into a metropolitan area
many worry about the impact of a dirty
bomb a conventional explosion that could
spew radioactive material and create
chaos and contamination at the other
extreme an actual nuclear detonation in
a large city would kill hundreds of
thousands if not millions of people
today's threats from nuclear weapons are
many including accidental use the
escalation of a military conflict or
used by terrorists in the face of these
threats the norm against testing is
already fact with near universal support
with a comprehensive nuclear-test-ban
treaty without testing it will be
difficult for any country to develop
nuclear weapons in New York more than
190 countries agreed to move towards the
elimination of nuclear weapons it's
important to close the door to nuclear
weapon developments and the test ban
treaty is part and parcel of this
program nuclear test by the Democratic
People's Republic of Korea in 2006 and
2009 demonstrate not only the dangers of
nuclear weapons proliferation but also
the capabilities of the international
monitoring system the comprehensive
nuclear-test-ban treaty organization
provided precise and uniform data about
all the tests to members of the Security
Council ahead of their critical
deliberations
today nations possessed over 23,000
nuclear weapons President Barack Obama
of the United States and President
Dmitry Medvedev of the Russian
Federation who command more than ninety
percent of the world's remaining nuclear
weapons recently signed an historic
agreement to further reduce deployment
of their Arsenal's the cold war is long
over the world's concerns have shifted
to other pressing international
challenges in 1991 President Nursultan
Nazarbayev of Kazakhstan unilaterally
shut down the world's second largest
test site recently the government of
Kazakhstan and other like-minded
countries sponsored a resolution for an
international day against nuclear tests
the resolution was adopted unanimously
by the General Assembly on the second of
december two thousand nine the
secretary-general visited semi peloton's
in april 2010 and described President
Nazarbayev decision to close down the
test site and banish nuclear weapons as
an act of extraordinary leadership a
visionary step and a true Declaration of
Independence I urge the leaders of
Russian Federation United States and
other nuclear weapons state leaders to
abandon all nuclear weapons since 1945
governments groups and political leaders
have worked steadfastly with
international organizations including
the United Nations to bring about a
world without the threat of nuclear
catastrophe non-aligned countries and
other nations from all corners of the
globe along with civil society led the
effort to eliminate nuclear weapons
during the Cold War and they lead the
fight for a safer world today they
recognize that an historic opportunity
exists to outlaw nuclear weapons once
and for all
you
the 2010 nuclear non-proliferation
treaty review conference final
declaration recognizes the overwhelming
interest by a vast majority of states to
explore alternatives for achieving the
abolition of nuclear weapons either by
way of a nuclear weapons convention or a
framework of related instruments as the
UN secretary-general has proposed
nuclear abolition has been humankind's
goal since the dawn of the Atomic Age
the world cannot wait for another
Hiroshima or Nagasaki or worse to find
the political will to banish these
weapons at a time when epidemic disease
poverty hunger and threats to the global
environment require enormous resources
trillions of dollars have been spent on
nuclear weapons the continuation of
wasteful programs that ignore basic
human needs and human rights and that
endanger us all will be overcome by a
public determined to make a better and
safer world for us and for our children
ambassador good afternoon first of all
thank you very much for bringing me over
here I will not speak as a
representative of the organization you
saw the film there is a statement which
was prepared so let me speak as as an
individual if you wish a global citizen
and I was watching the film i was
watching out of the window and I wanted
to ask you do you really believe that
things can go wrong and I think this is
an important psychological barrier
because if you look outside it's a sunny
weather we are sitting here in the
middle of New York can it really go
wrong yesterday I walked in the books of
barnes and noble and i saw some of the
publications about the 2008 financial
meltdown and it's amazing how much of
literature is there on what went wrong
ok triple w what went wrong analytica
coverage action is unfolding stimulus
packages up to 2 trillion if you take us
the European Union China new regulations
buzzer three but this is all about what
went wrong and my feeling is that there
is a there is a habit and this is the
habit of force to look upon things in a
in a positive way there is a certain
notion of infallibility it cannot happen
to me it cannot happen this time what we
saw it was the past it happened
somewhere else and it will not happen so
I just wanted you two to sync it through
because if I go back to the organization
from which I'm coming that has been
pretty there was a reference to the
partial test-ban treaty
of 1963 but the way that treaty emerged
it emerged against the background of the
Cuban Missile Crisis vino and you know
without the Cuban Missile Crisis this
treaty would not have happened I don't
know whether you so I recommend to
revisit even if you saw McNamara's film
fog of war there he said look we were
under the impression that there were no
mrs. nuclear weapons on the territory of
Cuba we're under the impression that
they were being transported went of them
and he revered in the 1990s he talked to
feed our custom and the information he
received really shocked him because the
information was no they were 162
warheads at that time on human territory
it was a close call too close to call
near miss but we had to go through and
politicians have to go through that near
miss to try to identify what went wrong
and as it is the case with the type of
action which is undertaken now sometimes
is just a quick fix sometimes it
something which which is temporary and
when we move on and we leave behind some
of the lessons which we should learn I
would like to recall the terminology
used in this financial meltdown this is
a terminology from from the nuclear
Aryan this this is a terminology for
nuclear reactors if anything is going
critical safety problem security
problems or combination of the two
nuclear meltdown so for something which
is grave and terrible there is the
terminology taken from from our area
which which we are focusing on
Warren Buffett mentioned that the
derivatives are the hydrogen bomb
hydrogen bond of the financial world
array again to describe something tough
there is a terminology there is a matter
for taken from for more area and this is
a reminder that yes a bubble burst the
financial bubble burst what could it
happen that the market forces of
deterrence do not work or they can work
today they can work tomorrow but what
happens if this irrational exuberance
these are the words used by alan
greenspan might underestimate how far
they they work and i don't think we
believe in that but could it happen that
there is a there is a there is a bubble
which is there could it happen that we
have to take more seriously what is
emerging in front of us called nuclear
Renaissance and yes this is the
direction the word your goal yes there
will be a significant increase of
nuclear energy there is a debate whether
it will be thirty percent or or a
doubling in the next 20 years but is
there a footprint of this development
which would require a closer attention
to the safety and security and the
safeguards attached to to to this
development is there a potential bubble
there as well McNamara in this fog of
war film shared ten lessons derived from
his own experience and and I think
someone who was probably the youngest
Secretary of Defense who was who was at
a very early age CEO Ford who was
described as a semi God or a God of
them analysis so he said that there is
this notion of infallibility where the
human race truly believes in
infallibility and another lesson of his
is that we cannot repeat what was the
lesson of the 20th century 160 million
people dead because the bubbles burst so
the bubble before the First World War
and the bubble before the second world
war because the market forces of
deterrence free competition races did
not work the the messages of course not
an analytical description of what went
wrong because this is what happened in
1962-63 leading to the partial test-ban
treaty by the way this is how the United
Nations emerged after the second world
war and after reviewing what could be a
fix yes this is how United Nations
emerged and this is how the first
resolution of the United Nations and the
nuclear weapons emerged as well but this
is how the League of Nations immersed
president Hassan said the first world
war is the war to end all wars and this
is how the League of Nations immersed
and it was a quick fix that was no
believe in it there was no ratification
of the of the Versailles Treaty in the
United States Senate and this is where
later it led to repetition or the war
which was meant to be the last war to
clear and all the wars so there is a
need to do to sink this row and and
there is a there is a bigger message
here I don't think we can leave with the
what went wrong analysis we do not want
to turn around Warren Buffett's world
and we do not want to try to see okay in
nuclear area what is a bear market what
is a recession what is a great recession
or God's sake what is a depression or a
great depression in the nuclear age we
do not want to think about it and this
is not a message only from McNamara by
now we have from the last nine
administration's of the United States to
third of the secretaries of defense and
secretaries of state who are saying that
nuclear weapons are not an asset anymore
these are liabilities and these are not
like blue eyed knife activists you might
describe as a blue-eyed naive activist
but these are people like Kissinger Oh
Schultz okay I don't think you need a
long introduction I need the long
introduction many of us need the long
introduction but I don't need I don't
they don't have to introduce any
Kissinger that that once he is
subscribing to something that it must be
serious for some reasons somehow we are
not getting their intellectually some
what we do not believe that McNamara who
who gained as a walking IBM this was the
reference back in the 1960s to McNamara
that he was right we do not believe that
these people these amazing statement and
politicians are a serious about it
because you do not believe that it can
go wrong and we do not believe to to
some of the scientists in the film you
saw Einstein yes we accept that Einstein
practically
link the dots for us with the exception
of the string theory he linked all the
missing dots how the universe works but
we do not believe him on this issue of
the danger of nuclear weapons yes he was
right on the on the theory of relativity
but somehow we are not digesting that
yes last I was calling for a test ban
treaty and Einstein was was lobbying for
something we are addressing here and we
don't do not believe to other scientists
we believe in our infallibility the
Ambassador mentioned today that this
event is not about Kazakhstan and it's
not about Kazakhstan is not about a
presidential decree but there is an
example which which I will have to a bit
translate for ourselves so there is a
country which inherited a test site this
is a this is a huge test side this is
the territory of of of Wales 18,000
square kilometers and this country
decides to close down this test side and
the country inherits nuclear arsenal
which has the best explained at that
time was the number for nuclear arsenal
so we are speak about 1400 warheads but
at that time it was none before if you
put it now in the context of the New
START treaty this is a second to none
nuclear arsenal by the number of
delivery vehicles which have foreseen
under the new Sun treaty the yield of
those weapons warheads was one Megaton
so in terms of yield it's even iron a
country decided to forfeit fuel cycle
elements it closed down fast breeder
reactor you you recall all the
discussions
this a country decided to know just to
close down the fast breeder reactor
which would have produced more fissile
material but the country decided to give
up something which could be presented as
strategic stockpile there was an
inheritance of three metric tons of that
and grade uranium which is again to
translate the equivalent of 120
additional warheads a country decided
turn itself from a nuclear weapon state
in the non-nuclear weapon state by imply
adhering to the non-proliferation treaty
a country decided to join among the
first the test ban treaty to give up
permanently in legally binding Lee in a
verifiable way husbands and the country
was the shaker and the mover of the
nuclear weapons-free zone in Central
Asia why i am recording for all of us
these facts because a country not just
articulated the right things to do but
the country did through deeds through
action the right things across the board
if not just arms control is not just
non-proliferation it's not just nuclear
disarmament if you put together all
these elements it's the the whole
spectrum the whole spectrum what can be
done and the whole spectrum of the
actions we need today was done by a
country and the question might be okay
kazakhstan I had no choice at that time
or or even if they had a choice and even
if they did that this is passed they no
country would do it today and here let
me bring you back to how far this
example of Kazakhstan was or was not
followed and 1991 this was the moment
when Kazakhstan closed down the
semi politics test sites after 400
million more than 450 nuclear weapon
tests kazakhstan was not left alone in
92 a moratorium was put in place on
nuclear tests in 1994 negotiations were
started I was sitting I was sitting in
the early 1990s in Geneva if anyone
would have asked me 91 that that would
you think that negotiations would start
in 94 on the test ban treaty it would
have not been a serious discussion
because it was a realistic and it
happened ok 94 and in a in a record time
of less than three years those
negotiations succeeded I spent my own
career 10-15 years on uncertain
negotiations Chemical Weapons Convention
was mentioned so three less than three
years it's absolutely unbelievable but
it happened and what happened as well
that all the nuclear weapon States sign
this treaty in September 1996 and France
closed down its test site as well so
what seemed to be a dream at that time
was turned into something as a reality I
think the test ban and Andy and the
existence of the norm the existence of
the norm which is shared by by nuclear
weapon states and non-nuclear weapon
States which is monitored by a
monitoring system a system which is
built by 182 countries and run by a 182
countries should be an inspiration that
yes we have to wake up yes we have to
act and yes is too low so this is my
message to
thank you so much
well let me say first of all how
grateful I am to have been invited here
and also I want to thank you all for
coming it shows you are interested in
this topic and it's very encouraging to
see this this level of interest of such
an important issue I would like to begin
by talking a little bit about this
problem that we have with the global
stocks of nuclear weapons many people
don't quite appreciate how serious a
problem this is and how large it is we
currently have around 20,000 nuclear
weapons in the world held by nine states
and this is a certainly far lower than
the 70 or so thousand that existed in
the mid-1980s at thigh at the height of
the Cold War but it's only relatively
it's about the same as the number that
existed when the nuclear
non-proliferation treaty was signed back
in nineteen sixty eight when there were
roughly 30,000 nuclear weapons so we're
looking at at a very modest reduction
over a period of forty years and which
is a cause of some concern another cause
of concern is the fact that the
doctrines that inspire the use of
nuclear weapons are spreading along with
the weapons themselves we have the
notion of nuclear deterrence for example
that is now practiced in various forms
by nine countries where a country's
security is premised on the threat of a
lethal retaliation involving nuclear
weapons the third problem that we're
facing right now is the fact that the
all of the states that have nuclear
weapons have in various forms or another
modernization programs underway they're
either building more delivery systems
for these weapons or they're trying to
approve the weapons themselves the
warheads themselves this is a sauce or
of concern another was cost many many
here might not realize exactly how much
these weapons cost the Brookings
Institution did a study in 1999 of the
total historic costs of the US nuclear
weapon program alone just one country
and this was done in 1999 the estimate
that they calculated was five point six
trillion dollars now I don't know
whether you can visualize what a
trillion dollars looks like or five
point six trillion dollars I have
trouble visualizing it so Brookings did
a calculation and they figured that if
you started a stack of one dollar bills
from this spot here and you kept on
adding dollar bills to that until you
got five point six trillion you would go
from here to the moon and almost all the
way back to earth that's five point six
trillion dollars now that's one country
and that's ten years ago now we have
also the three dangers that were cited
in the film you just saw the dangers
from existing Arsenal's the dangers from
the spread of these weapons to
additional countries and the danger that
the weapons will be acquired by
non-state actors or terrorists the
problems that exist in the current
possessor states are very serious ones
they include the risk of accident
accidental use or unauthorized use and
also accidents involving the weapons
themselves there is for example off the
coast of Georgia right now in the United
States a nuclear weapon that was lost in
the late 1950s a hydrogen bomb it was
involved in an air crash it's never been
found there have been bombs that have
been dropped out of airplanes out near
spain in the polymerase incident there
was bombs that have blown up on runways
like in the landing in Greenland for
example they
involved in fires they have been fallen
out of airplanes they have actually
exploded the chemical weapons inside of
them these are so called Broken Arrow
incidents they've even been the subject
of popular movies so we're looking here
at a problem that has not gone away it's
a very serious challenge that still
remains and fortunately I think that
there are a number of extremely positive
developments that have been happening in
recent years I think the public is
coming to realize the seriousness of
this threat and I think there's really a
convergence of three different political
forces that are underway right now that
are pointing in a very positive
direction you could even say I suppose
it worth we're looking at a perfect
storm of three different forces on the
one hand we've got leadership from the
states that have nuclear weapons which
are in particular the United States and
the Russian Federation the leaders
presidents Obama and Medvedev have been
personally reiterating time and time
again their own commitment to zero to
achieving a world free of nuclear
weapons this call has been echoed by
leaders of all the other states that
possess nuclear weapons literally all of
them so there is a harmony of you will
at least of the goal involved of
achieving zero there are major
differences of course on the means to
get there but at least we can take some
comfort in some the fact that there's
agreement on a goal the other vector or
force if you will in the world is from
the diplomatic community from leading
countries of especially middle powers
countries that are showing their
leadership and statements and speeches
and resolutions in the General Assembly
in creating such things as an
international day against nuclear tests
is another form way of showing
leadership in inspiring action by in co
itions in by acting in groups like the
new agenda coalition for example that
has formed in the United Nations and has
been very very successful in moving its
its priorities in in integrating them
into General Assembly resolutions new
agenda coalition by the way consists of
Mexico and Brazil Sweden and Ireland
Egypt in South Africa and New Zealand so
it's a very diverse interesting
coalition of middle power states now the
third layer or escalon if you will of
this political force that we're looking
at in addition to the nuclear powers and
the diplomatic community is civil
society and we were seeing a resurgence
of interest in civil society in many
many ways which I'll let Jonathan
explained in his contribution in just a
moment but so I do take some comfort in
the fact that that although we have
these huge hurdles ahead in dealing with
these existing weapons the danger of
their spread and the danger of their
acquisition by non-state actors they're
still as this enormous pushback coming
from the world community and civil
society that has to be supported and
strengthened over the years in
preparation for my talk here today I I
reread a speech that Kofi Annan had
given on the seventeenth of November in
the year 2000 at John Jay College where
he talked about the role of the Academy
over academia in advancing disarmament
and it was a interesting speech it
identified three different functions of
the role of universities discovery
training and education and advocacy
discovery is essentially research
focused on preparing reports and
scholarly articles about the facts about
nuclear weapons that are not commonly
known a great deal is not known about
nuclear weapons including even how many
there are in the world today it's only
recently that we've been starting to get
more trans
perrin see these facts and figures so
there's a rich amount of research to be
done on these topics that the academic
community can certainly contribute to
they also have a very important role in
training and in educating a new
generation of leaders who are going to
be coming into the world and as voters
as taxpayers and as legislators and as
other people working in the
bureaucracies or international
organizations around the world is
vitally important that they have that
kind of background and the third is
advocacy which is the pressing of the
disarmament issue with political leaders
and through op-eds and editorials and
political action and we'll be hearing
more about that later today the cause of
disarmament has been significantly
promoted and assisted by a series of
events that have happened one after the
other in a very fast sequence over the
last three years even the the nadir the
rock-bottom came I think in the year two
thousand five with the collapse of the
nuclear non-proliferation treaty review
conference which ended in disarray and
no consensus and that was followed a few
weeks later by another failure of the
World Summit to address any disarmament
issues what so ever since then things
have been changing a former US nuclear
weapon policy makers like George Shultz
William Perry Henry Kissinger and Sam
Nunn have written a series of editorials
in The Wall Street Journal pushing hard
on the disarmament theme this has been
followed by a proposal by
secretary-general ban ki-moon in october
two thousand eight his five-point
nuclear disarmament proposal there was a
for the first time in un history there
was a summit meeting of the heads of
state to address disarmament issues
first time ever that was in 2009 in
September President Obama made his
speech in Prague in April of 2009 where
he identified the goal of the security
of a world without nuclear weapons there
was a Nuclear Security Summit in
Washington on the
role of this year a very successful
review conference for the nuclear
non-proliferation treaty for a change in
May of this year and there was a
historic visit of Secretary General Ban
ki-moon to Hiroshima and Nagasaki in
august six than August ninth of this
year the first time any
secretary-general has ever visited those
two cities on the occasion of the peace
memorial ceremonies so things are
happening and things will be happening
on the twenty-third of September there's
a ministerial-level meeting of the cup
of these signatories of the
Comprehensive Test Ban Treaty which will
we be held at the very high level
meeting at the United Nations follow the
next day by another high-level meeting
on dealing with the future of the entity
called the conference on Disarmament
where multilateral treaties are
negotiated so I think in conclusion I'd
like to just say that we have huge
difficulties ahead we have to rely on
academia and to make a major
contribution to this effort and I want
to tell you right now that I'm reading
the book by Richard Rhodes called the
making of the atomic bomb and Here I am
standing here in Columbia University at
the Italian Academy and a good part of
that book is about Enrico Fermi and the
work that he did at Columbia on making
the atomic bomb and I find it very quite
appropriate that here we would be
meeting today discussing the making of
nuclear disarmament and I think that
we'll be having more of these meetings
in the future at least I would certainly
hope so and recommended so on that note
I'll stop and give my colleague Jonathan
a grin off the floor thank you
thank you very much I want to thank
ambassador at Tom ova for her initiative
and in this and there's a woman a verra
meta very quiet woman who you know
there's always somebody who just does
all the detail work for these things and
and I just think whenever there's ever a
social movement it's those people who
just work late at night and on weekends
and nobody sees them that get stuff done
and i'm just going to unmanaged out her
it's very meta who was doing that and i
want to i want to give her a round of
applause how many people here are in the
in the school of international relations
social work okay law I don't know how
many here are not from the United States
Wow ok so we are largely not from the
United States so I will try and make
sure that this is not a us-centric
speech because you know I had to know
that and I find it very interesting that
the vast majority of the students here
are not not from the United States so I
i'll begin i'll throw out the speech
that i had prepared which was very
focused on getting the US Senate to
ratify the START treaty and then the
test ban treaty and just kind of honed
to the facts I got my gasoline yesterday
from a Russian concession I my computer
was on the blink last night and I was on
the phone with a young woman from
Bangalore and the money that I used to
pay for these goods and services was
supplied by a blown from China and what
these
three countries have in common is they
have enough nuclear arsenals essentially
to end all life on the planet earth and
I was reflecting on what is the role of
the state in such a situation if the
state's first duty is to protect its
citizens and we know that we are all
challenged by addressing the climate of
the planet protecting the oceans where
seventy percent of the fishing stocks
are at risk or the very pH of the ocean
is at risk levels of cooperation to
address these very pressing threats are
absolutely imperative if we're to
address the fact that we have a global
economy that's integrated on wall street
address the fact that anything that
happens anywhere affects people on Main
Street and that half of the world's
population is living with no Street
today it's already a catastrophe for so
many people we have to reach new levels
of cooperation so I look and say what
place do these devices these devices of
unimaginable destruction play in the
world that we want to live in a one
Megaton bomb just to get it's hard to
get your imagination around it would be
equivalent according to ambassador
Thomas gram of the United States of a
train with TNT from Los Angeles to the
United States within a thousandth of a
second the heat that would come out of
one of these devices is three times that
of the face of the Sun at four miles it
would blister aluminum surfaces at six
to seven miles it would set fires to dry
leaves and at 16 miles you would have
fires bursting out from wool anything
flammable it's unimaginable the
destructive capacity of these devices in
the in the book the last train from
hiroshima Charles Pellegrino describes
the so-called ant walking alligators
survivors that he that were seeing
where people were eyeless and faceless
their heads transformed into blackened
alligator hides displaying red holes
indicating mouths the alligator people
of Hiroshima did not scream their mouths
could not form sounds the noise they
made was worse than screaming they
uttered a continuous murmur like locusts
on a midsummer night one man staggering
on charl charlie was carrying a dead
baby upside down I read the testimony of
witnesses of Ibaka Shaw witnesses the
atomic Holocaust that befell the people
of Hiroshima and Nagasaki and the story
simply boggle the imagination it's just
simply we're just not capable of
fathoming the destructive capacity that
we are every day preparing to unleash
our this country my country alone spent
over 52 billion dollars on this
enterprise last year with no public
debate and you have to question why and
what is it risk I call it the oops
factor is the one that I'm most
concerned about yeah of course I've
concerned that a terrorist might get
ahold of one of these issues one of
these weapons the issue that concerns me
is the existential daily reality of
having these weapons ready to be used
one it undermines all moral discourse it
undermines all moral discourse of an
interpersonal nature what are we doing
talking about right and wrong when we
allow this to continue what are we
allowing to keep we're allowing a
situation where in 1983 Stanislav Petrov
was watching the computers in in Russia
in the then soviet union and there was a
computer glitch that said that the
soviet union was under a full-scale US
attack and he did not pass on the
information up to command and control
because if he had he knew
at the amount of time that the military
leaders would have to use their weapons
before they would lose them was not
enough and he felt that they would would
use them as ronald reagan said six
minutes ins is insane to ask somebody to
make such a decision they probably had
maybe 10 minutes now the interesting
thing was I interviewed him for a
documentary that some Norwegians are
doing and I asked him what gave you the
courage and the humility not to you know
not to pass the information up and he
said well when I was a computer engineer
and I knew they made mistakes and to I
talked to God and God said he didn't
want the world to end and then he said
the interesting thing was when they were
evaluating we need to determine whether
they would court-martial me or reward me
they're real they're real concern and
that got the guy that got the generals
above him really angry was not that he
violated his orders or to praise him for
saving the world what really bothered
them was that he believed in God 3am
1979 all of the all of the warnings went
off in the United States the Pentagon's
National Military Command Center the
alternate military command center in
Fort rich Maryland the American
Aerospace Defense Command in Cheyenne
Mountain in Colorado Springs the
national emergency airborne command post
the president's doomsday plane was
ordered in the air as President Carter's
National Security Advisor Bresnan ski
was preparing to call him the threat was
reassessed at 2200 missiles coming at
the United States enough to end the
United States and by fall out nuclear
winter the entirety of civilization what
had happened Senator Charles Percy of
Illinois was turning a defense facility
and the officers wanted to impress him
of the seriousness of their mission and
one of the technicians mistakenly put
the wrong training tape in the computer
and the whole system went haywire and
President Carter would have had less
than 15 minutes to decide the fate of
the future of all humanity
the cold war ends you'd think this would
be over right 1995 a weather satellite
is launched off the coast of Norway and
the Norwegians tell the Russians about
it but somehow it doesn't get passed up
the command and control and the first
launch is a burst an electromagnetic
burst in the atmosphere that fries the
electrical systems of your adversary so
the fact that it's one missile doesn't
mean that it's not a full that it's not
an attack and it looks like a trident
launch and the so-called football is
opened and Yeltsin has less than 10
minutes to decide whether to use his
nuclear arsenal or lose it and thank God
he wasn't drunk no human being should
have the fate of the world in their
hands in that way it is totally insane
Bob McNamara said Robert McNamara that
ambassador Toth referred to said you
can't use nuclear weapons against a
country that has them it's suicidal it's
patently immoral to use them against a
country that doesn't have them and there
are no use against terrorists the
intellectual arguments in favor of them
are so thin and hollow I'll give an
example august 3rd 2009 a Wall Street
Journal op-ed by Douglas faith former
undersecretary of defense for policy
under under George Bush one of the
people who got us into the Iraq war and
Abraham shill ski one of his colleagues
and intelligence colleague who helped
get us into that war they argued that if
the United States fails to modernize its
nuclear weapons its friends and allies
would lose confidence in the nuclear
umbrella of extended deterrence and they
themselves become nuclear weapon states
well they know that Japan and Germany
have been advocating strongly for
ratification of the Comprehensive Test
Ban Treaty for a fissile material cutoff
treaty for all of the elements that walk
us down the road
the elimination of nuclear weapons but
they're unconstrained by facts just as
they were unconstrained by facts leading
us into that horrible warrant that we in
in Iraq they are unconstrained by facts
you must understand what we're dealing
with we're dealing with people for whom
the ideology of the pursuit of raw power
the the law of power has become more
important than the power of law because
what does the law say the law says the
International Court of Justice addressed
the issue in 1995 and unanimously ruled
that there is a legal duty to negotiate
the elimination of nuclear weapons the
International Court of Justice said that
any use of nuclear weapons pending their
elimination must comply with
international humanitarian law which has
elements proportionality the
discrimination between combatants and
civilians not affecting neutral parties
and not unnecessary suffering and not
destroying the environment and it's
inconceivable that you could have a
nuclear exchange that wouldn't violate
those principles of humanitarian law and
the arguments that the United States and
the United Kingdom posed before the
International Court of Justice was well
we could drop one in the high seas and
it wouldn't violate that or we could
drop one in the desert and it wouldn't
violate it but that's not the reality of
what we're dealing with we're dealing
with weapons that would on aisle eight
the cities of the world and the
countries of the world all except for
Israel Pakistan and India members of the
nuclear non-proliferation treaty agreed
in two thousand and recently in 2010 to
an unequivocal undertaking to obtain the
total elimination of nuclear weapons so
that's the treaty agreement that's the
statement of the highest court in the
world and yet there's a lethargy because
I don't think people see a route to get
there and I'm going to just give it to
you very very simply in the Broadway and
then put a challenge to you as students
here at Columbia University first we
have because of the horrific effects
that biological or chemical weapons
would have we have treaties banning them
we have a chemical weapons convention
that bans chemical weapons and we have a
treaty banning biological weapons now
imagine if the biological weapons
convention said that no country can use
smallpox or polio as a weapon but eight
countries are so responsible that we can
entrust international peace and security
in their hands and they can use the
plague as a weapon we would all say that
is morally incomprehensible and
practically unsustainable for it would
be but that's precisely the regime we
have with nuclear weapons we have every
country in the world prohibited from
getting them and nine countries saying
we have a right to have them and pursue
international peace and security using
these horrific threats and it is morally
incoherent and practically irrational
and that's why people like Henry
Kissinger and George Shultz are coming
out i'm on a project with george shultz
we're with the United religions
initiative we just wrote a letter to 22
million five hundred thousand people
about our initiative to get the
religious community to stand up on the
moral grounds on this George Shultz this
was Ronald Reagan Secretary of State it
just amazes me but they've seen the
impracticality of it and they've
reflected on the morality of it for
we're no longer enemies we no longer
have existential enemies that we did so
there needs to be a convention a treaty
banning nuclear weapons exactly the same
way as chemical and biological weapons
and all we're waiting for those of us
who work in the field is a group of
countries to get together and say let's
begin a preparatory process to get there
let's put the map on the table and let's
get to it let's put the flag in the
ground the Secretary General has done it
and why that's important is it changes
the fulcrum of the debate I'm reminded
of of alice in wonderland with the
Cheshire Cat you know she gets there and
he says how can I help you she says I
don't
which road to take and he says well
where do you want to go she says I don't
know he's then it doesn't matter and
that's kind of where the world is now
every year it's a different crisis du
jour oh you know Iran might get them or
somebody else might get them and we lose
our focus and that's why the focus has
got to be a treaty banning them the
second is the country of Norway had a
windfall profits from their oil our
billions and billions of dollars so
there were some very forward-looking
parliamentarians there who said let's
set up criteria for the investment
investment criteria and we don't want to
invest in in enterprises that pollute
and destroy the environment we want
because we're putting the money aside
for future generations and we don't want
to give them a planet that's that's
polluted and let's also prohibit that
this money be used for immoral purposes
we will prohibit the investment of this
money in enterprises that produce
weapons of indiscriminate effect
biological chemical or nuclear weapons
so the money is now invested in such a
way that they have a list of companies
that they cannot invest in because they
pollute the environment and companies
make money from land mines cluster
munitions and nuclear weapons the
university columbia university has
pension funds it has investment policies
it i believe that it's time that
students stood up and said we don't want
columbia university to be investing in
enterprises that pollute the environment
that's easy you get a lot of student
supports for that right away nor do we
want Columbia University investing in
enterprises that produce weapons of
indiscriminate effect if some of you
will take that on as a challenge and
start asking about that I assure you
that it will create political momentum
and that's what's needed the moral
imperative is there the practical
imperative is there but the
psychological hurdle is high if you take
one step in the right direction I assure
you you will feel the wind of history
behind your sales you will feel the
voice of your own conscience empowering
you and you will find that people will
join you I hope you do that thank you
well we have a few minutes left for
questions and I'd like to invite those
who wish to speak to our distinguished
panel here please to come to the
microphone and raise any questions that
you might have we have about maybe five
or ten minutes for questions
one thing I ran in North Korea have
nuclear weapons capabilities I mean I
remember 2003 we were talking about Iran
developing nuclear weapons and we said
that they should have enough for several
devices within several months it is 2010
seven years later supposedly they're
building their nuclear facilities in
deep bunkers that are protected against
conventional weapons now didn't do clear
devices that you're talking about the
new ones are specifically geared toward
the destruction of these bunker
facilities there are many the bunker
buster nuclear bombs the many nuclear
weapons they have a very practical use
in the prevention of Iranian and North
Korean nuclear capability but they
themselves those weapons are nuclear I
mean how do we protect the citizens of
this world when there are rogue states
like North Korea and Iran with religious
and communist fundamentalist you know
who can't feed their people and who
can't provide freedom and democracy when
the people are you know revolting in the
streets they just shoot them down so you
tell me okay you tell me what do we do
about those countries and countries that
aspire to that sort of mentality do we
have a speaker there
and concrete or sub state actor wanted
to deliver a nuclear device to us they
would they wouldn't do it using a
missile or anything like that but these
countries you lookin dirty they would
put in a bale of marijuana which we seem
to be unable to prevent from getting
into the country I was in Iran in April
in their conference on nuclear issues
and the head of the country issued a
fatwa their religious leader said that
nuclear weapons are immoral and so it'll
be very difficult for them to actually
develop nuclear weapons they have to
really change their whole structure and
policy and then we'll authority that the
leadership but they clearly want to be
nuclear weapons capable they want to
have the same technology that other
countries like Japan have so what we
need to do universally because you're
talking about the crane I call these the
crisis shore because there could be more
countries and that goes I usually talk
about the oats factor which I talked
about and then the bozo factor the bozo
factor is that you can have bozos
running any country at any time bozos
yeah and so of the fact that we have
bozos running Iran and North Korea right
now it doesn't mean that any of any
country could have such dangerous
leadership and that tightens the knee to
get control of the nuclear materials
globally the technologies out there and
any bozo country that gets the material
and produce the bombs and they can do it
surreptitiously South Africa did it if
they do South Africa didn't run a
program less than 75 million dollars and
they did it with technology
radio shack what they didn't have what
they had to get elsewhere it was the
nuclear materials so right now what is
really needed is an internationalization
of the production of the fuel cycle to
control it and we have to rapidly get to
a normative regime of verification that
locks down all the nuclear materials we
never lost an ounce of gold from Fort
Knox and we've got to treat nuclear
materials the same way Iran accepted
intrusive safeguards and they were very
upset that what they got for that was
accused of being part of the axis of
evil that can be changed changed so
North Korea is simply an exam midwifery
is a different situation but North read
us about the same kind of threat but in
the long term we have to quickly get
control of the fuel and make sure
there's not an ounce of it that's not
inspected and clamped down and that's
probably going to need some form of
international fuel bank cuz that's the
issues how do you how do you guard the
fuel
but you know there's also a future
nuclear that we have a discovery this is
a relatively new technology so with
nuclear propulsion systems diffusion in
California so you generally raises the
question about future technologies and I
think that argues very strongly in favor
of what we're saying which is that I
would agree with you I think that
science is going to march forward what
science is going to do is it's going to
broad provide fewer people with less
resources greater destructive capacity
and it's for that reason that the
institutional structures that render
weapons of mass destruction morally
politically and practically impossible
to build have to be put in place nuclear
weapons leave a fairly large traceable
footprints even the production of them
we know where how to make that we know
what they do and that's why there's so
much momentum look 182 countries in the
world of renounce the entirety of the
southern hemispheres of their weapons
free there's the treaty of quality logo
which makes about an American nuclear
weapons-free decree of our tango making
the South Pacific degree reference free
entry of melon dabra making Africa
nuclear weapons free east regime and now
there's the treaty that that Constance
and helped lead to get recently a treaty
making Central Asia nuclear weapons free
so and in each of these regimes there
are inspection regimes and trust and
confidence is built some countries don't
want to build them threatened one
another we need to make the northern
hemisphere like a southern hemisphere
it's often just one brief response then
and we'll take another question but it's
often assumed that in any nuclear
disarmament situation that you have the
nuclear powers unilaterally giving up
their weapons and then just crossing
their fingers and hoping for a better
world in fact that will not happen they
will not give up their nuclear weapons
unless they have absolute confidence
that there will not that their security
will not be eroded in
such system the reason that the much
effort is being devoted to exploring the
contents of a nuclear weapon convention
is because precisely you have to know
what the details are about how you will
detect cheating how you will ensure that
against surprises like that the three
terms that you hear in the UN a lot as
criteria for any responsible disarmament
agreement are irreversibility
transparency and verification clearly
any convention to get 20 would have to
have ironclad controls on each of those
three areas you have to know where the
fissile material is how many warheads
there are where confirm their
destruction and you have a highly
intrusive inspection and detection
systems that are including remote
sampling environmental sampling
satellite monitoring you we haven't even
heard a briefing today on the the the
unbelievable detection capabilities of
the Comprehensive Test Ban Treaty
Organization for going after even really
really small nuclear explosions they
have a superb ability to do that and
it's growing so by the way we're also
not talking about um the risks of
disarmament if you're going to talk
about risks let's also assess risks of
not having disarmament and risks of the
status quo everything is relative it's
good to keep that in mind yes question
Thank You Marcus Brooks an alumni of the
University and I must say this is one of
the best panels I've seen on this topic
so thank you so much my question is to
anyone has there ever been a buyback
program of any sorts with I can't
understand the complexity but yet has
ever been a buyback program of any
source with nuclear warheads or just
nuclear material in general well there
in a way there has I used to work in the
Senate for Senator John Glenn in the
middle of the 1990s there was a program
called Cooperative Threat Reduction
program or otherwise known as the
nunn-lugar program where the United
States purchased 500 tons
of highly of enriched uranium now this
enriched uranium was was had once been
very highly enriched and was used in
either in submarine fuel or in nuclear
warheads and they took it and they
blended it down to be low enriched and
then it came to the United States and
has now been converted into fuel for
nuclear power plants and I think it's
something like ten percent of the
electricity generated in the country is
from is from that fuel it's a classic
case of swords into plowshares now that
is just one example of how this could be
done I think that your question though
may have been directed more for in terms
of proliferation risk or are there
scenarios where a country's security
could be assured or there could be some
compensation for dismantle matt i think
that almost certainly that will be the
case in North Korea where there will
have to be some package of security
assurances and probably some financial
incentives as well so i think yes there
is possibilities for that but it's a
very limited case i think
at the grid point on the previous
question I simply approach absolutely to
my phone on the second question how to
make sure the current is accessible safe
secure and the are some significant both
the best and you can set this compost
but we have to invest efforts to give
you one example the amount of nuclear
energy use in the next time to use my
own way it might not reach that level
there are certain user to decrease by
certain person if it happens there will
be a corresponding increase in number of
facilities the volume of the fissile
material which is used the volume of the
extent to which is removed from the
reactor the number of the people who are
having X
we are sticking with just about OS CD
copies but the major
yes and if any of these elements go
wrong like he was
Venice any one of these three elements
go wrong it will be catastrophic
gorgeous area
energy because as it happened operation
over there was a low blow less loss of
interest from practically 86 on 420 so
there is a relationship and there is a
yes there is a sony to make sure that
safe securus in the use of New Berlin
Jesus only on the Iranian issue I think
it it's a question of to which level one
can invent romantic eras I don't think
we are still there and it's a question
of judgment that is a hour span of these
issues my own feeling is that if you
daily Deza 3d Iran
why because it has nothing to do is
probably morning military and military
activities and the international
community should practically expose you
are situational other day one it's in
the hands of rebar to prove
is on the on the issue of North Korea
knee on the beyond a certain level of
course not easy to deal with the
computer
interests are secretly might divide that
there might be longer
but they're in the cohesion of evil it
is a sebacean package which might
cooperate improvisation the poor de
panama specific consumer should take
series is no test need each and every
one
we are running over just a little bit
but I see there is one more question and
I'd like to give this gentleman
opportunity my name is Marianne Rochon
off thank you for this interesting panel
today and my question is for I have two
questions for mr. Randy rattle first is
what is the what is your perspective
vision for the potential disarmament of
the remaining may night nations that
still possess nuclear weapons today and
my second question would be about the
role of academia that you raised in your
speech don't you think that this role of
academia is a little bit exaggerated
maybe instead we should discuss more
about the more comprehensive approach
involving the role of governments in
this in resolving this issue or perhaps
NGOs and civil society thank you I have
a request hear from our one of our
panelists our distinguished panelists to
to address part of that question please
laughs but of course government's way up
to the pressure on but the United States
for example it is the University of
California system that runs some of the
labs so we actually have a merger and
the intellectual resources for the
enterprise as dr. Rydell pointed out at
the beginning were largely actually
cared this university but I'm a great
importance is the fact that once you
accept that nuclear weapons are an
unacceptable risk and that they normally
are more about
they seek to solve and that they sit
over everybody's head today then
wherever you are wherever you are you
have a duty to work on the issue and
because we're in a university I
emphasized that but if we were in church
I would emphasize that next week my
organization the global security
Institute one of our programs is
convening about 20 countries in Nations
in Geneva and we will address what they
should do but I talk to my neighbors and
you know and I think everyone wherever
they're sitting especially the
democracies should be demand of the
kahlua political representatives and
their economic institutions to change
this issue so it's whatever you are um I
would just underscore the my agreement
with what Jonathan has said I'd like to
say that looking ahead to the future in
looking for what the true litmus test
what what you would really want to see
as concrete evidence of the disarmament
being taken seriously is what arm is
missing right now which is what i call
domestic domestication domestication
occurs when you have a global norm that
takes root into domestic law legislation
regulations budgets and institutions now
unfortunately none of the nuclear weapon
States has any disarmament ministries
none has a disarmament that I'm aware of
disarmament budget none has domestic
legislation requiring setting deadlines
timetables timelines etc so there's a
lot of work to do in taking these these
commitments that have been made
internationally and having them take
root in domestic laws and policies
there's been some progress in that area
but that's that's where I would look to
see whether we're really making headway
the other is the evolution of the rule
of law and the whether there is any
progress in actually sitting down and
talking about the outlines of what a
nuclear convention would look like what
would have to be in such a treaty
just hypothetically so that you could
have confidence that the disarmament
would be woody comply with these are
very very good questions to pose and it
were a good time to do it I would submit
to you though that none of these
questions will be asked and none of the
changes will happen unless you have a
configuration of three political
influences voices of civil society the
pressure from the diplomatic community
and leadership by the nuclear weapon
states I think those are absolutely
indispensable and academia has a
contribution to that I'd like in closing
to to express my deep appreciation to
Dean Nakamura for her efforts in or in
organizing this meeting to the to the
Italian Academy for hosting this and for
the whole school of social work for
providing such a marvelous opportunity
for us to get together and to ambassador
a tmobile for her not just a eloquent
statement but for her real leadership in
this very difficult field and for all
our other my distinguished panelists
here thank you all very much for coming
and I apologize to you personally for
keeping you over just a little bit
and just in case if you will be in Times
Square night night why evening time at
least just pay attention please on CNN
table and you'll see 30 second every 15
minutes 30 second just shot very short
somehow feel about the international day
against nuclear tests thank you thank
you so much and we are looking forward
to see you again